non on continue et on continue alors
cette fois je vais vous mettre patrick
devedjian dans les mains de linda hardy
attention il est un volume d'à d'abord
il ya quelque chose pour ressembler à mr
bean
cette déclaration est par contre non non
c'est non c'est juste je sais pas je
fais une comparaison comme ça par contre
on peut dire votre âge oui 55 10 à 55
ans vous faites plus jeune que votre âge
voilà vous êtes mariée à l'âge de 25 ans
est ce qu'il y ait beaucoup d'autres
avant aux femmes en france qui n'a eu
d'autre oui beaucoup
combien marié puceau quoi personne
croire et ça non bombe vous êtes de la
droite d'un homme de pour les valeurs de
la famille on peut imaginer que la
tension montait alors à quoi avez vous
renoncé par un amour pour elle elle
trouva pas assez de choses en tous les
cas ils pas à la politique
oui elle trouve que c'est pesant enfin
elle a accepté avec beaucoup de courage
mais je trouve que c'est pesant donc à
vous êtes pas on peut ici elle m'aide et
là d'autant plus de mérite que les
autorités mais le temps des affiches
c'est fini avant jean panneton
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous
agace particulièrement chez votre femme
et ce depuis 30 ans depuis s'exprimant
ce oui oui oui bien sûr mais 16 elle
ouvre tout le temps les fenêtres partout
et l'arrivée elle ne ferme pas les
portes
alors ça fait des courants d'air et
saint malo comment tu comprends d'après
leur versant oui mais voilà est-ce que
chez les débuts du en se réconcilient
souvent sous l'oreiller
donc tout le monde dont tout le monde
quand vous avez l'impression qu'elle
fait une faute de goût vous lui dites
aussi ne pas se rendre compte qu'on
essaie voilà elle trouve non elle trouve
que je ne gagne et elle trouve que je ne
suis pas très recevable dans ce genre de
critique et elle m'accuse d'être
daltoniens parfois en manie en matière
d' harmonie des couleurs ces biens
l'avocat qui parle je ne suis pas
recevable dans ce genre de côté mais lui
téléphoner et pour lui dire quoi
deux ou trois fois par je peux lui dire
quoi pour lui dire mais l'envoyé de fous
rires et je t'aime c'est parfois ses
subalternes je le reconnais que kasparov
et après les meetings vous l'appelez
rendre vous coucher il l'appelait oui
tout le temps tous les jours pas tous
les jours mais souvent quel genre de
rapports que vous entretenez votre
belle-mère d'excellents rapports avec ma
belle mère
le mérite à doha si tu me disais ma
belle mère est adorable usa dimanche et
qui les bords qui assomme les cas ces
maudits l'amour hors mariage vous a déjà
tenté bien sûr donc on imagine que vous
avez beaucoup de femmes qui vous courent
après je n'en suis pas convaincu mais
quand on voit une jolie femme comme vous
par exemple on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
l'admirer la line dance a décroché sans
patron du rpr
est ce que vous faites dimanche matin 11
heures généralement la grasse matinée
c'est peu traîne non avec une direction
paris l'om ça qu'on pensait que vous
seriez la messe mais on peut rallumer la
lumière merci